a packed house as the mini plenary
kicked off in Brussels as proceedings
were opened a call for countries to do
more to stop al-shabab killing innocence
and prevent tragedies at sea as a marg
was also paid to 400 people feared
drowned of a Libyan coast thus Midland
million often get teeth about currently
so vitamin da swear schwag me noted for
wounded the daughter I'm League inaba
and improbably Zeb's and that's he needs
a revision of the multi-annual financial
framework budget is in the pipeline 20
1.1 billion euros was left over from
2014 the aim is to ensure that the
budget can be adapted to meet needs
quadro finance a durian wall perceive
that the flexible enough preciso de
llamar revision is taken quanta ansiedad
Shimon and Siddharth doing preview Yetta
meant by flexible it up but a
programmers knob and finally Parliament
remembered a hundred years since the
Armenian Genocide a day after Turkish
Prime Minister Erdogan criticized the
Pope for labeling the world war one
killings as genocide any piece called on
Turkey and Armenia to reconcile the past
folk Ahmad was one of her commode men
escaped felons ala alfredito kya